you think every instrument is its own
journey is you play guitar you play bass
you sing just the the Mastery of an
instrument or let's avoid the word
Mastery the understanding of an
instrument is its own thing or they
somehow
like physical manifestations of the same
thing it's both you know like every
instrument has its strengths Beauty
limitations range like possible range
that can you know be extended to some
degree or another depending on who you
are like trumpet or something you know
like some people can hit higher notes
than others blah blah blah but um that
being said we're all playing the same 12
or 24 or however you divide the octave
that many notes you know we're all
playing the same notes so in that sense
it's all the same thing it's just music
or better yet it's just OD or expression
but yeah every instrument has you know
you got to go through the the
physical the physical aspect of it the
motor skills and all of that and
hopefully you get through that really
quickly so you can get to the
expression quickly because if you get
stuck in just that first phase that's be
really boring yeah but that's a that's a
pretty long phase the
technical the the the technical skill
required to really play an instrument
for some people it's a long thing and
some people it's short it very very much
varies it might have to do with like how
you learn um and getting to know like
your strengths in learning like more
oral or more like is it more like K like
what's what's your strength and playing
off of those strengths so for me like it
was like like I was saying earlier it
was just an intuitive thing that I knew
I can feel when my brain is full like
that it needs processing time and so I
listen to that I don't push past it uh
even if it's like one minute and I do
something I'm like
okay silence and then I come back and it
and on I trust that it's going to be
there and is there so just trusting
yourself I think is really important
trusting that you know you better than
anybody else is going to know you so
that's the kind of thing with with
teachers that can be either really
really helpful and great or really not
great like I'm primarily self-taught
I've had amazing mentors of all walks of
life and I think I'm unbelievably
blessed that my mentors are some of my
favorite musicians on Earth whether it's
Leonard Cohen or Jeff Beck or Wayne
shter whoever these people are like they
are my favorite musicians
so not everyone has that opportunity but
what the opportunity that we have now
that I didn't have when I was starting
is that everything's on YouTube like
every interview with every genius like
you you don't need to necessarily have
these people in person now I mean it and
and then I'll say to that yes and no I I
agree with myself and then I don't agree
with myself and and the reason is I do
believe that there is something that
happens when you're in person with
master um in some cases that there is
something transferred that is not
intellectual it's not spoken as
something else that happens that can
happen and that I've experienced and um
I really value that and I think that
applies to specific disciplines and also
generally like I've been around Olympic
gold
medalists just to hang out with them for
several days and there's something
there's something about greatness
there's a way about them that kind of uh
permeates the space around them and you
kind of learn something from it even if
you don't practice that particular
discipline yeah there's something to it
if you're if you're able to see it I
also like what you said about the
playing stuff in your
head that
it forces you to not be um lost in the
in the physical learning of the
instrument
I think that's one of the things
I probably regret a little bit so I play
both piano and guitar and I've become
quite over the years technically
proficient at the instruments but I
think my mind is underdeveloped because
of that meaning like I can't really
like
um I can feel the music when it's
created but I can't
create out of the feeling I haven't
practiced the U project projecting the
feeling onto the music you know what I
mean and I'm not like a musician but I'm
just it it's it's a different muscle
that I think is if you really want to
create beautiful things you have
to the creation happens here not with
your hand I think it's more here or what
whichever it's some part of the body but
it's not with your fingers yeah cuz I
think the fingers is more this sure and
then yes is here yeah right it's just
nice that you said that cuz it it um
it's probably really it's really good
advice if you want to create yeah
slowing down is really great too what do
you mean slowing down slowing everything
down it could be you know I can play
something really fast but I may want to
like practice
it
yeah
[Music]
like go slow as possible cuz there's all
these micro movements and that are
happening that if you just
go like you you can't pay as close
attention to the exact tone that you're
pulling from each note
and there's a lot to pay attention to to
how my fingers are touching the string
here like I can change my tone A Million
Ways just by the direction of this
finger and same with how this lands and
how hard I'm attacking the string and
with what intention am I hitting the
string
emotionally physically and so even if
you can
go play that so slow see how locked into
a pocket you can be see how you like
feel every aspect of that cuz then when
it gets sped up is still there with you
mhm yeah that's brilliant it's kind of
like the transcended and included thing
that Ken wber talks about like it's like
and I guess that's what meditation can
do for you is to like really listen to
like observe every aspect of your body
the breath and all this here you're
observing every element like every super
detailed element of playing a single
note yeah that's it's cool that if you
speed it up it's still there with you it
is I I yeah it is cuz I hear there are
certain people it's like they play
really fast but I don't hear the
fullness of tone always and it's like
well it's probably because maybe they
didn't maybe it's cuz they didn't slow
it down and really sit with each note
and let it like resonate through their
whole being it's spiritual it's like a
spiritual expression it's not just like
like you know it's not it's not a sport
a lot of people treat music like a sport
yeah since starting to learn more like
Steve yon versus Jimmy
Hendricks I I would spend a quite a long
time on single notes of just bending
just like just listening to what you can
do with Ben's
spending just thinking like people like
BB King and all these Blues musicians
like spent a career just making a a
single note cry yeah there's like anart
form to that yeah and I think you
putting it like taking it really slow
which I never really thought
of it's really good idea like really
slow it down it's the same with like
sitting with your own emotions it's like
we when emotions are overwhelming to us
we get real busy or we move real fast
because it's like we don't want to feel
our feelings and those are the moments
to slow yourself down and observe it
anger jealousy and just be with just be
with it be like be cool with it like
love it love the
anger